We're back
(audience applauding)
with the hilarious Kym Whitley
(hand tapping)
and Finesse Mitchell!
Yes.
(Ross applauding)
(audience applauding)
I am just having so much fun.
And there's something
that Ross is gonna tell you about
that is really doing it for me,
and we're gonna do it,
(Finesse chuckles)
and I'm thrilled. Go Rossy.
Well, this is so exciting,
I saw this.
Actually, my fiance, Wellington showed me this
and I was like-- I sent it to the news team.
We got to try it.
It's a new party game for you and your family.
People posted a video of the funniest family ever.
Look, playing a game where you have to get a cookie
from your forehead to your mouth
with no hands.
(Finesse chuckles)
Look how hard this is.
And then try--
(audience laughing)
You got to wiggle it down.
(Kym chuckling)
So, we have some cookies--
(Ross chuckles)
That's made me laugh so hard.
(Finesse chuckles)
So, do you guys wanna try it?
Yes.
All right,
we have some cookies here.
Okay.
All right, hit the music!
We can do this.
(quirky music)
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
(quirky music)
And you don't get to eat it until it--
(indistinct)
It's so hard.
(quirky music)
I know.
No!
(quirky music)
Oh, man.
I got it, I got it, Drew. (quirky music)
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
Hey,
(indistinct)
Oh, man
(quirky music)
(audience cheering)
(indistinct)
(quirky music)
(audience cheering)
Oh.
(Kym shrieks)
(indistinct)
It's too hard.
Oh, man.
I got it.
Did you get it?
Yes, I got it.
You nearly got it.
Yes.
(Finesse and Ross laughing)
Liar.
(Finesse chuckling)
I did,
I did it with my (indistinct)
You have to try this at home,
it is so hard to do.
Oh my God.
Drew, you got this,
you got it.
Drew is focused.
Just flip it.
(audience cheering)
Drew, Drew, Drew
(audience clapping)
Go, go, go,
Drew, Drew, Drew
Go, go.
(audience clapping)
Oh, she's gonna do it. (audience clapping)
Watch this.
Oh my God, she's focused.
I believe in you.
(audience clapping)
(audience cheering)
(indistinct)
Turn down,
turn down, turn down!
Turn down, turn down!
Turn down!
(audience cheering)
Yeah!
(Finesse chuckling)
(audience applauding)
(indistinct)
What kind of face muscles
do you have?
(Ross chuckles)
Look, look at you.
Look, look, look.
Boom!
Oh my God.
(Finesse chuckles)
You are--
(audience cheers)
(hand thuds)
You--
Oh my God, look.
Please put that on ESPN.
(Ross laughing)
That has to make SportsCenter Top 10.
I have to say, Finesse,
I don't know if he heard it,
but you said that was more exciting than the Super Bowl.
I have to agree,
that was the best thing.
It was,
that was the best.
Thank you so much,
and Rossy,
(indistinct)
(indistinct) bump.
(Ross grunting)
Yes!
She did it.
(audience applauding)
(Ross growls)
I really didn't won on that,
that was for Ross.
You know I was watching--
I didn't wanna let him down.
All right,
(Ross chuckling)
Kym Whitley and Finesse Mitchell,
please let's do this again.
(audience applauding)
Please come back.
I'll do it any time.
Please,
we'll be right back.
Thank you. (upbeat music)
(upbeat music fades)